Resuelve para "y" y verifica tu solución.
20 menos "7y" es igual a "6y"menos 6
Lo que voy a hacer es llevar las "y" a un
solo lado y si nos encontramos con un coeficiente
que esté multiplicándola podemos dividir
ambos lados de la ecuación entre ese coeficiente.
Las "y" las podemos agrupar del lado derecho
o del lado izquierdo de la ecuación, de hecho,
voy a hacer ambos casos.
Para empezar, me parece que es más fácil
agrupar las "y" del lado derecho
y te lo voy a mostrar en un momento.
Así es que si quiero agrupar las "y" del
lado derecho,
¿cómo puedo eliminarlas del lado izquierdo?
Así es que si del lado izquierdo tengo "-7y"
ó "7y" negativo, podemos sumar "7y" a ambos
lados de la ecuación, sumamos "7y" a ambos
lados de la ecuación
¿y qué nos da?
Del lado izquierdo tenemos 20 menos "7y" más
"7y", "-7y" y "7y" se cancelan y nos queda
tan solo 20, ¿y del lado derecho qué tengo?
"6y" más "7y" que es igual a "13y" menos 6.
Ya tenemos las "y" del lado derecho.
Ahora, para deshacernos de este menos 6 que tenemos, necesito sumar más 6 a ambos lados de la ecuación.
Sumamos más 6 del lado derecho y sumamos
más 6 del lado izquierdo, ¿qué nos da?
Del lado izquierdo, "13y" menos 6 más 6,
nos queda tan solo "13y",
menos 6 y más 6 se cancelan y 20 más 6 del lado derecho nos queda 26...
esto es igual a "13y"...
Ahora, aquí tenemos "y" ó 13 multiplicado
por "y", si quiero despejar la "y",
lo que tengo que hacer es dividir
entre 13 o multiplicar por 1/13.
Así es que vamos a dividir entre 13 ambos
lados de la ecuación, dividimos entre 13
del lado izquierdo y dividimos entre 13 del lado derecho,
¿qué nos resulta?
"13y" entre 13, nos da simplemente "y",
los 13 se simplifican
y del lado izquierdo nos queda, 26 entre 13 = 2.
Hemos obtenido la solución, "y" igual a 2.
Ahora regresemos, ¿por qué mencioné que era más fácil agrupar las "y" del lado derecho?
Pues porque de esa manera obtuve un coeficiente
positivo del lado derecho, "13y", sin embargo,
si hubiera restado "-6y" a ambos lados de la ecuación, del lado izquierdo hubiera obtenido
"-13y", que también es válido, déjame mostrártelo.
Escribamos la ecuación...
20... no, lo voy a hacer con otro color,
lo voy a hacer en turquesa.
20 menos "7y" es igual a "6y" menos 6.
Ahora, vamos a restar "6y" a ambos lados de
la ecuación, "6y" menos "6y" y menos "6y",
¿y qué nos queda?
Del lado izquierdo nos queda 20 menos "13y"
esto es igual a "6y" menos "6y" se cancela
y nos queda tan solo -6.
Ahora, ya tenemos las "13y" del lado izquierdo,
necesitamos deshacernos de ese 20,
para lo cual vamos a restar 20 a
ambos lados de la ecuación,
y ahora esto se cancela, por eso hicimos eso,
nos queda "-13y" es igual a -26.
Ahora dividimos entre -13, dividimos entre
-13 ambos lados de la ecuación...
dividimos entre -13 y tenemos aquí del lado
izquierdo, -13 por algo entre -13 nos da ese
algo, esos -13 se cancelan, nos queda simplemente
"y" que es igual a -26 entre -13 = 2,
aquí agrupé las "y" del lado izquierdo, mientras
que aquí agrupé las "y" del lado derecho.
Hice primero del lado derecho para que todo
quedara positivo, pero lo que hicimos aquí
también es perfectamente válido.
Ahora, lo último que voy a hacer es asegurarnos
que obtuvimos la respuesta correcta.
Podemos estar tranquilos pues obtuvimos la
misma respuesta de las dos maneras,
pero vamos a verificarlo.
Sustituyamos "y" igual a 2 en la ecuación,
para verificar que se obtiene una identidad.
Tenemos 20 menos 7 por "y" que es 2, esto es
igual a 6 por 2 menos 6.
Del lado izquierdo tenemos 20 menos 7 por
2, recuerda que la multiplicación se hace
primero, 20 menos 14, esto es igual a 6 por
2 = 12 menos 6, 20 menos 14 es igual a 6,
12 menos 6 es igual a 6, 6 es igual a 6, así
es que nuestra respuesta es correcta.